se avienta un par de datos de seis caras
mil veces y se registra la suma de los
dos dados eso suena bastante lógico por
ejemplo si que hay un 3 y un 4 se
registra 7 los resultados están en la
tabla de bajo usa esta información para
estimar la probabilidad de que la suma
de los dos dados sea 7 la siguiente vez
que se avienten los datos vamos a ver
que aquí tenemos las número de veces que
ha salido el número 7 y tenemos 7 ha
salido 175 veces de las mil veces que lo
hemos lanzado así es que podemos decir
que tendremos
175 posibilidades de cada 1000 que se
han lanzado de acuerdo a la tabla que
tenemos aquí si lo queremos ver como
números decimales lo pondremos como
175 milésimos
175 milésimos comprobemos la respuesta y
es correcta